in other news this morning we learn a  short time ago that 85 year-old Justice  Ruth Bader Ginsburg is in a Washington  hospital with three broken ribs Ginsberg  is the oldest Supreme Court justice and  the senior member of its liberal wing  according to a statement she fell while  working in her office last night at the  court she got up she went home  but then after experiencing some  discomfort she went to the hospital  early this morning to be examined and  was admitted Ginsberg has overcome a  series of medical problems including two  cases of cancer and another fall that  broke two ribs in 2012 she was  hospitalized just hours before President  Trump visited the Supreme Court for a  ceremony welcoming justice Brett  Kavanaugh